support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
I'll move university comm the link will
be in the description below thank you
and enjoy
no video series on the basics of
chemistry is complete with at least
without at least mentioning the periodic
table of elements so before we get into
it I have three questions that I want to
sort of ask get out of the way before we
start talking about it the first one is
what is an element right we're talking
with the periodic table of elements what
is an element an element simply is a
substance a substance that cannot be
broken down any further now that isn't a
simple definition I'll talk more about
it in the next video but for now that
can kind of be it well I guess I'll
mention also that an element is made up
specifically if only one atom but we'll
talk more about that later basically an
element is the simplest type of matter
okay which is why we have this table to
help us keep track of the different
simplest forms of matter right how many
elements are there currently as of July
2015 there are 118 known elements and
approximately 90 of them occur naturally
which means that some of these were
discovered in labs with chemists sort of
doing their thing okay so another
question is who came up with this thing
genius dude Russian chemist Dmitri
Dmitri Mendeleev Mendel of like that I
think I spelled that correctly so what
he did was he's pretty brilliant what he
did was uh at the time there were a
certain number of known elements and
what he did was he arranged the elements
that they were known at the time by
relative masses by relative masses or
specifically B what we know now or what
we call the atomic mass and he grouped
them according to their reactivity or
their properties
okay
and what he did was when he put this all
together and at least initially when he
arranged him by these masses and put him
in certain groups that of elements that
reacted similarly what he did was he
found holes or gaps in in the table
where an element was oops I wrote a
table there gaps or holes in the table
where he thought okay there there's a
missing element here but what he did was
he made predictions about that element
that little unknown element and about
their properties so the hope was that
when they were discovered that they
would have the properties that he
predicted and that actually turned out
to be the case I think at the time there
were two elements gallium and germanium
numbers 31 and 32 here and I'll get to
what those numbers mean a second they
weren't there but he didn't know about
aluminium silicon and he thought um you
know gallium should be similar to
aluminum and germanium should be similar
to silicon he guessed certain different
things I won't get to all the details
about what he specifically guessed but
the point is that they were discovered
and a lot of his predictions were pretty
much right which is crazy
that's pretty genius if you think about
it okay so basically he gave rise to
what is now the the modern day periodic
table which is shown here and we'll talk
a little bit about it and how to how to
look at it and and sort of so we can
understand what's going on here
what Mendeleev initially did was he
arranged them by relative masses now the
periodic table is arranged by atomic
number which is the number of protons an
element has so each one of these little
squares or kind of like rectangles but
each of these little blocks represents a
particular element and we've got this
little key here to the right the number
on top is the atomic number that's
actually the number of protons we'll
talk more about that in the video on
atoms the letter or
letters is the atomic symbol and often
what happened what is the case actually
is that the letter is the first letter
of the name of the element or the first
two letters or at least two letters of
the name sometimes it's in English
sometimes it's in Latin Latin for
instance the H is hydrogen so I'll write
that down over here to the to the left
so the H is hydrogen H E is helium
so those were in English but na is
sodium so that's kind of weird right but
it's it's actually named for or the
simple case is from naturam
which is sodium in Latin okay um just W
down here number 74
that's tungsten right tungsten but
that's come that comes from the German
wolfram and if my pronunciations of
those are wrong in any way to people who
speak those languages I apologize
anyway um but most often though it's the
first letter or first two letters of
that element or at least two letters in
that elements name and that last that
last number at the bottom is the the
average atomic mass should basically be
if you add up all the different isotopes
masses and divide based on the relative
abundance of those that doesn't make
sense to you quite yet but it will later
okay unless you already know this stuff
anyway another thing that you'll notice
is a lot of these symbols are written in
black if they're written in black that
means that that thing is a solid at at
the temperature of zero degrees Celsius
or 32 degrees Fahrenheit 273 Kelvin okay
if it's written in red like hydrogen or
helium up here it's a gas at that
temperature if it's written in white
like bromine over here number 35 and
mercury HG number 80 here that those are
liquids at that temperature and if it's
gray it's unknown that's basically
because the those elements for whatever
reason are assuming that for whatever
reason those elements are not stable
enough to really figure it out in fact
some of them are have their masses
written in in parentheses the
parentheses to know that the the the
mass of either the
most stable isotope or the isotope with
the longest half-life okay some of these
don't actually make sense but don't
worry about that at a certain point
you'll be able to refer back to this
periodic table and make sense of what
I'm saying now something that's pretty
crucial to understand is that there are
rows and columns which is probably
pretty obvious from but what's important
to note that the rows right going left
to right are are called periods that's
why it's called the periodic table okay
so there are how many rows there are one
two three four five six seven you might
think eight nine but that's not the case
of because these two rows are actually
supposed to fit right in here you notice
on the color-coding fifty seventy
seventy one kind of belong here eighty
nine to 103 kind of belong here so there
are seven rows in the periodic table
seven periods okay and then there were
columns right there are 18 columns that
are shown here 18 columns the columns
are called groups okay so we mentioned
before that men to live sort of group
things according to the reactivity and
properties that's still the case here
views things that are in columns the
elements are in the same column have
similar reactivity in properties it's
actually really really crucial to
remember similar reactivity and
properties try to fit that in there in
fact a lot of them have a lot of the the
groups are specifically given particular
names so we can remember them by so you
can see here that there are eighteen
columns 1 through 18 going left to right
right the columns of course are up and
down so this orange column yellow column
does these two blue call on the band but
you'll notice that there are some that
are numbered 1 a 2 a and 3 through 8 a
over here the first two columns last six
columns those are called the main group
elements and part of that just because
they're they just show up kind of often
in chemistry okay so scroll this down
just a tad bit more so um how many
columns or groups are there well I just
said 18 so we could say that right 18
groups but what you can do is because
these guys these last two is purple and
red row down here at the bottom they're
kind of taken out of the table put below
it they they can be considered their own
columns right these 14 if you count from
left to right those 14 columns there and
you can think about them as being
different groups because of their
electron configurations which might not
make sense to you quite yet because we
haven't covered electron configurations
but you could look at this as 14 groups
in addition to the 18 up here so you
could think some people will depending
on who you ask
you might see some people say 18 columns
or 18 groups versus 32 okay because then
of course this this 32 is just coming
from the 18 that are up here plus the 14
down here right which would be 32 excuse
me 32 columns or 32 groups okay so what
are the names of these groups and what
are their some tidbits of knowledge that
we should or might want to be familiar
with this first group here group 1a
excluding hydrogen actually before I
even mention that um there's this dark
block here this dark sort of staircase
right here little
order here this little border separates
the left side of the table from the
right side basically things to the left
generally speaking our metals and things
to the right are nonmetals okay now
that's the general this is generally
speaking right within that there are
specific names for specific groups okay
that's what we'll go over now
so this first group Group 1a excluding
hydrogen it's called the alkali metals
the alkali metals so they are soft
silvery metals that are particularly
violently reactive with water and they
can cause a little tiny explosions like
if you put lithium a small piece of
lithium in water it can spark a little
bit a little mini explosion you put
rubidium or cesium it can cause a much
larger explosion I don't recommend that
you do that just to be clear but also
they're called alkali because if they
react with water they can get basic
products okay the the group right next
to them to a group to a is the alkaline
earth metals okay and they also react
with water to give basic products hence
the alkaline name and they do react
somewhat violently with water but not
nearly as violently as their as Group
one a elements the purple group here in
the middle or swimming uh purple this
light sort of pink group here faint pink
those are the transition metals there's
a bunch to say about that about them but
I won't really talk about it right now
it's just an intro video and I think
it's pretty long already
but that little block there is called
the transition metals and the the the
next group here the sort of like tannish
gray here
they're called the post transition
metals and sometimes they're called the
main group metals I've seen because
they're metals that are part of this
main group right 1a 2a all the way to 8a
right between 3a a so since they're in
that main group element block sometimes
main group metals this sort of dark
green here along this sort of staircase
these elements are called the semimetals
or metalloids okay and the reason why is
because they're kind of at that border
between the metals and the nonmetals and
they these elements can sometimes have
trades of metals and some trades of
nonmetals of course now that things to
the right of that are the nonmetals
things in in the green are nonmetals and
these next two groups 7a and 8a are also
nonmetals but they have specific
specific names group 7a is called the
halogens and they they're called that
because Hal comes from the Greek meaning
Greek word meaning salt and they're
involved in lot of salts in fact you
might have heard of table salt being
sodium chloride so I'll write that down
here sodium chloride NaCl a lot of times
the alkali metals or the alkaline earth
metals would be interacting with one of
the halogens to make salt in fact NaCl
is table salt sodium chloride is table
salt all right so that's an alkali metal
with a halogen this last a column over
here at the very end 8a these are the
noble gases sometimes called the inert
gases because they're not very reactive
okay I'll actually write that word to
the side there inert inert gases the
last two down here these these are
called the the inner transition metals
in our transition elements are in their
transition metals and they are called
the the first the row here starting with
LA called the lanthanides and the group
right under it started with AC or called
the actinides okay they're together they
are the inner transition metals okay now
generally speaking when it comes to
metals they are solid shiny malleable
malleable basically means that they can
you can kind of alter their form you can
like bend and change the the shape of
metals and doesn't mean it's easy but
you can you probably see now like people
like meltdown weapons and stuff like
that or change the form of weapons or
like Bend an iron bar or something like
that
ductile basically means that you can
form it into wire so like you guys might
know with copper wire copper is you
right here number twenty-nine metals are
also good conductors of heat and
electricity so they allow heat not just
to flow very well um that's especially
important when we're talking about
ductile because electricity right we
need electricity close we know it flows
through wires right so that should make
sense a little bit there
nonmetals most of them are gases of
course at this temperature bromine is a
liquid carbon phosphorus so for selenium
and iodine are all solid that can be
pretty colorful they can be brittle if
they are solid and there are poor
conductors of heat electricity
semimetals kind of have the traits of
both right they're shiny like metals are
but they can be brittle like nonmetals
are and they're semiconductors they're
sort of not really good conductors and
not very good insulators they're kind of
somewhere in between and yeah that's
about it I hope that video was helpful
as an intro to the periodic table of
elements
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful be sure to fiddle with the
like and don't forget to subscribe if
you haven't already also be sure to
share the video with anyone you think
might find it helpful thanks and happy
studying